[Music]
which episode of the original star trek
was so bad that leonard nimoy was still
embarrassed about it years after the
fact and why did one walking dead star
almost quit acting entirely keep
watching to find out
few people have been in more star trek
projects than jonathan frakes this means
that despite all the wonderful memories
as will riker frakes also remembers a
whole lot of bad moments for instance
frakes himself called the next
generation episode code of honor a
horrible racist episode and allegedly
tried to get it pulled from syndication
however the scenes he regrets the most
aren't in the next generation instead
they come in his one episode appearance
in enterprise where he provided the
framing story for the series finale
these are the voyages the problem frakes
feels that his presence was a disservice
to the regular cast of the show as riker
permeates the episode appearing at
dramatic times that should belong to
other characters like the traumatic
death of commander trip tucker even the
last line of dialogue in the entire
series is spoken by riker rather than
one of the show's regular cast members
computer
and programs
frakes has called it an unpleasant
memory in 2011 he told fans at central
canada comic con
they said it would be a valentine to the
fans but all it ended up doing i think
was hurting scott bakula's feelings he
was such a gentleman about it and i said
to scott this is weird for me to be on
your show i wasn't crazy about it bakula
himself has never spoken about the
finale but the tensions were clearly
there as writer producer brandon braga
called it the only time scott bakula was
ever mean to me
though enterprise is often considered a
low part of trek's history many fans
still have an affection for it and few
characters from the series get more love
than trip tucker played by connor trunir
but trunir wasn't happy with his
character's pointless death and his
biggest issue with it had nothing to do
with riker looming in the background
instead it was just the disappointing
way tripp died blowing himself up to
take out three randos
as trenir told trek today i've gotten
out of much worse scrapes than that
malcolm mcdowell played one of the most
important villains in star trek history
as dr tullian soren in star trek
generations he was the force that united
jean-luc picard and james t kirk he was
also the man who kinda killed kirk using
a delayed response bridge collapse as it
turns out mcdowell thought that was
pretty stupid in 2011 he told
startrek.com if you have this icon of
american television why the hell didn't
they give him a spectacular death why
did they give him such a really paltry
death me shooting the bridge out or some
bs whatever it was
they should have sent him off in a
glorious fashion and they didn't
the scene originally had soren shoot
kirk in the back before reshoots
mcdowell also found this disappointing
and he lamented that they couldn't
figure out a better death he told metro
it was feeble i thought because i
thought he deserved better
william shatner has spent decades as one
of the faces of star trek and when
you're the head honcho of the uss
enterprise this comes with many great
moments but it also comes with many
deeply embarrassing ones
some of these were a product of the time
period others were a product of
shatner's own ego but the scene he
publicly regrets most is his final scene
when asked by crave online whether he
was satisfied with kirk's death in star
trek generations shatner replied no
no i would have done something else
according to shatner the suits at
paramount figured the star trek
franchise might make a lot more money if
they included the next generation cast
they also allegedly reasoned that there
wasn't much milk left in the original
series cash cow so it was a perfect time
for kirk to meet picard and they also
wanted to kill off kirk in order to
raise the stakes and signal a permanent
changing of the guard shatner told
trekmovie.com that he was presented with
two options it was either i was going to
appear and die or they were going to say
he died so i chose the more practical of
the two between the lackluster reviews
and the pathetic death shatner wasn't
happy he said i wish that there had been
more trumpets for the death of the
character
fun
as [ __ ] leonard nimoy was there for many
of star trek's greatest moments it's
easy to picture him performing a vulcan
nerf pincher explaining how the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
but he was also front and center for one
of trek's worst hours spock's brain an
episode that was deeply embarrassing for
him
though it aired a half century ago
perhaps no episode has come to symbolize
trek at its worst more than spock's
brain
the episode sees spock's brain
surgically removed and kidnapped by an
alien species vulcan physiology lets
their bodies stay alive for 24 hours
without a brain so kirk goes hunting for
it
even for 60 scifi that was a bridge too
far in his autobiography i am spock
nimoy singled it out as a particularly
painful memory writing
frankly during the entire shooting of
that episode i was embarrassed a feeling
that overcame me many times during the
final season of star trek
though deep space nine is considered the
gritty star trek it still had a fair
number of off-putting moments including
some from no-nonsense commander benjamin
cisco when asked at a convention what
his least favorite scenes were avery
brooke said it was a toss-up between two
choices the first was move along home in
a scene that even the deep space nine
documentary what we left behind called
out as the worst scene in the series
he knew right away that he'd never live
it down saying there's nothing wrong
with the melody it's the hopscotch part
the second was apocalypse rising in
which he played a klingon which involved
enough prosthetics that it necessitated
a dentist appointment but while he
didn't want to do it brooks had no
choice he said the resistance you
observe with cisco playing a klingon was
real
dr julian bashir initially received some
backlash from deep space nine fans he
was seen by some as boring brash and
worst of all kind of annoying but while
the producers had a plan to make him
more interesting they didn't run it by
actor alexander siddig first the episode
dr bashir i presume reveals that bashir
was genetically modified as a child
which made him much smarter but siddig
didn't learn about this plot development
until the day before shooting he was
upset that the producers wouldn't go
over a major character arc with the
actor actually playing the character so
he staged his own personal protest he
told trekmovie.com
i did it the only way that an actor can
i completely destroyed the lines that
they gave me regarding the situation he
tanked the storyline putting no effort
into it going so far as to pin the lines
up on set so he could just read them
instead of memorize them
it might have been petty but it was
probably pretty satisfying nonetheless
few star trek characters were more
grounded than next generation's dr
beverly crusher except of course that
one time she fell in love with a ghost
in a magic lamp sub rosa is often listed
as one of the worst episodes of the next
generation an attempt at gothic romance
in space the story in somewhat reductive
terms involves beverly falling in love
with a ghost inhabiting a lamp it's
worth mentioning that this lamp ghost
has also seduced several generations of
her family needless to say actress gates
mcfadden found the whole concept absurd
in 2012 she told the crowd at austin
comic con i was reading this going this
woman became a doctor and she's in love
with a lamp i love lamp
do you really love the lamp are you just
saying it because you saw it
i love lamp
i love lamp
armin shimmerman is best known as quark
on deep space nine but years before ds9
was ever conceived he had a part as a
frankie on the next generation not just
any ferengi either but one of the first
ones ever put to screen and he regrets
every second of it the ferengi were
introduced in the last outpost just a
few episodes into the new series the
ferengi were meant to be menacing
threatening and anything but funny
nonetheless they came across as comical
and the episode is held in low regard to
this day their credibility as villains
tanked and they were mostly comic relief
until deep space nine shimmerman blamed
himself telling gamespot
no one bears the brunt of that mistake
more than i do so shimmerman approached
quark as an attempt to salvage the
ferengi all of my work on deep space
nine for the first four seasons was me
trying to eradicate that original
performance from everyone's mind
one of the all-time great comedic
actresses teri garr has played in
classics like tootsie and young
frankenstein she also played roberta
lincoln in assignment earth the season 2
finale of the original series it was one
of her first speaking parts and she
later credited it in her autobiography
with getting her real roles that doesn't
mean she liked it or even wants to talk
about it though gene roddenberry
intended assignment earth to be a
backdoor pilot to a new series hedging
his bets in case star trek got cancelled
ultimately star trek got a third season
and assignment earth remained a
standalone episode but years later when
interviewed for star log magazine gar
said i did that years ago and i mostly
deny i ever did it exactly why gar
disliked the experience so much as
unclear though producer bob justman said
in his book inside star trek that gene
roddenberry pushed to have gar wear a
shorter and more revealing skirt
whatever happened it was enough to sour
her on the whole franchise and fan base
she was glad assignment earth never
launched saying
otherwise all i would get would be star
trek questions for the rest of my
natural life and probably my unnatural
life you ever see those people who are
star trek fans the same people who go to
swap mates
you'd be forgiven for missing the fact
that jeffrey dean morgan appeared as an
alien in the enterprise episode
carpenter street as he was completely
buried in makeup and he hated the entire
experience
in 2003 morgan's career wasn't doing so
well and he needed work so he took a
role in enterprise he expected to do
some line readings instead he got four
hours a day in a makeup chair he told
entertainment weekly i remember them
dripping goop on my face and i had straw
sticking out of my nose i couldn't eat
lunch i was claustrophobic i'd go home
in tears the whole process was so
miserable he almost quit acting luckily
he didn't and the job helped him stay
afloat until better things came along
don't threaten me with a good time
garrett wang doesn't openly regret many
scenes he played as ensign harry kim
rather he regrets the scenes he didn't
get to play namely any as a senior
officer wang still takes umbrage with
the fact that harry remained an ensign
throughout star trek voyager telling
star trek.com i mean come on people kim
was probed beaten tortured and held the
distinction of being the first voyager
crew member to die and come back to life
what more does a guy have to do to get
promoted to lieutenant for frack's sake
wang called writer producer brennan
braga during the fourth season to ask
why harry hadn't been promoted he was
told quote well somebody's gotta be the
ensign check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite sci-fi
franchises are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you